herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live es
geht um die us-wahl und es ist nicht
übertrieben zu sagen dass kein
drehbuchautor ein spannenderes
dramatischeres drehbuch hätte schreiben
können als eben diese us-wahlen joe
biden der herausforderer oder doch
donald trump wer wird der neue us
präsident sein der am 20 januar 2021
vereidigt wird zur stunde in dieser
minute können wir es noch nicht sagen
aber es gibt entwicklungen da kann man
sagen dass joe biden derzeitig derjenige
ist der am nächsten am sieg ist der die
nase vorn hat und vielleicht auf die
zielgerade einbiegt man könnte sagen er
ist dem sieg sehr sehr sehr nahe im
moment der alle wissen die magische zahl
ist 270 wer von den beiden trump oder
beiden trump oder beiden von den elektro
it college wahlleuten 270 wahlmänner und
frauen hinter sich vereinigen kann der
wird wohl am 14 dezember gewählt und
dann am 20 januar zum neuen us
präsidenten vereidigt aber schauen wir
uns genau die situation an 214 wahlleute
hat donald trump bisher gewonnen joe
biden blau 253 hinter sich vereinigt das
werden sie sagen das sind doch zahlen
die hab ich gesehen hat sich gestern
abend ins bett gegangen bin
das stimmt aber in den letzten stunden
hat es dramatische zumindest spannende
entwicklungen gegeben und dafür schauen
wir in die einzelnen bundesstaaten rein
sie sehen hier blau die staaten die tour
beiden gewonnen hat roth vor allen
dingen das zentrum der vereinigten
staaten die bereits an donald trump
gegangen sind und gelb das sind die noch
hart umkämpften us bundesstaaten alaskan
nicht zu entscheiden können wir
weglassen aber hier arizona nevada
nevada arizona wären joe biden
diese beiden staaten gewinnen sollte
dann hätte er präzise 270 wahlleute
hinter sich dann
eher durch dann wäre er neuer us
präsident aber auch hier wird noch
gezählt auch hier ist es noch nicht klar
wer diese staaten gewinnt schauen wir
allerdings auf einen ganz anderen staat
nämlich hier georgia da sind bereits 99
prozent der stimmen ausgezählt es ist
mega knapp das entscheidende aber ist
die entwicklung das ist der trend denn
gestern noch lag
donald trump hier vorne knapp natürlich
18.000 stimmen was ist das schon aber
dieser vorsprung ist geschmolzen er ist
gesunken und im laufe des heutigen tages
hatte joe biden gleichgezogen 49,4 zu
49,4 prozent
unglaublich wie gesagt spannender kann
man es nicht machen das entscheidende
ist aber donald trump hat es liegt
zurück joe biden ist bei der präzisen
stimmenauszählung vorbeigezogen und es
ist eine ilse entwicklung vor zwei drei
stunden waren es 1000 stimmen die die
beiden vorne lag vor zwei stunden 1500
und jetzt sind es im moment 1584 es ist
ein gewisser trend der in georgia statt
findet trotzdem die aktuelle entwicklung
16 uhr 30 unserer zeit erklärt der
secretary of state von georgia ein
republikaner
dass die wahl dass die stimmen
wahrscheinlich neu ausgezählt werden um
auf nummer sicher zu gehen das ist doch
völlig korrekt der abstand zwischen den
zwei kandidaten wir sehen es ja hier ist
so gering dass man um fair zu sein um
auf nummer sicher zu gehen definitiv neu
auszählen wird es steht also
hundertprozentig fest dass wir in den
nächsten stunden nicht wissen wer die 16
wahlleute aus georgia für sich bekommt
aber schauen wir und das ist die
spannende entwicklung in den letzten
stunden auf einen ganz anderen staat
schauen wir auf diesen staat hier oben
pennsylvania und pennsylvania ist
insofern mega entscheiden 20 wahlleute
würde joe biden pennsylvania gewinnen
dann wäre er mit 273 wahlleuten in
seinem rücken durch er wäre der neue
us-präsident pennsylvania war aber so
schien es in
trumps hand denn gestern noch hat er mit
100.000 stimmen mehr als hunderttausend
stimmen geführt aber dieser vorsprung
ist geschmolzen
und wenn wir uns das jetzt anschauen 95
prozent der stimmen sind ausgezählt joe
biden ist im heutigen im laufe des
heutigen tages an donald trump
vorbeigezogen 49 14 49,3 prozent mega
knapp aber auch hier eine entwicklung in
pennsylvania lag vor wenigen stunden joe
biden in führung mit wie gesagt wenig
stimmen 5587 doch das ist angestiegen
6800 jetzt aktueller stand 8800 stimmen
damit scheint sich etwas zu bewahrheiten
was die beobachter ja in den letzten
tagen gesagt haben die späten
briefwahlstimmen die ausgezählt werden
die jetzt in dieser späten phase
hinzukommen das sind doch mehrheitlich
demokratische stimmen die also jetzt joe
biden helfen das heißt es könnte so sein
dass dieser trend sich weiter fortsetzt
joe biden also vielleicht in
pennsylvania seinen vorsprung weiter
ausbaut und sollte er hier alle 20
wahlleute bekommen dann wäre er
definitiv der nächste der neue
us-präsident und wir haben die chance
direkt nach pennsylvania jetzt zu
schalten
in philadelphia ist alissa jung meine
kollegen alisa wo bist du genau und wie
sieht die lage aus
ich bin leider gerade um die ecke
gegangen ich habe um die ecke gehen
müssen vom kongress zentrum wo also
jetzt gerade in der stunde in der minute
ein protest stattfindet weil ich sonst
zu schlechten empfang gehabt hätte er
wird mich nicht gehört also deswegen
stehe ich jetzt hier einmal um die ecke
hier ist es netz bisschen besser was
aber dort gerade passiert ist da stehen
sich also zwei verschiedene gruppen
gegenüber im protest und auf der einen
seite sind es menschen die fordern
jede stimme zählt alle sollen ausgezählt
werden
und auf der anderen seite also wirklich
gegenüber sie sind abgesperrt von den
von einer absperrung dazwischen steht
die polizei dass da eben es nicht zu
tumult kommt stehen trump unterstützer
innen und die und die fordern und die
sagen es soll auch hier in philadelphia
neu ausgezählt werden weil sie sehen es
genauso wie der präsident und trauen der
ganzen sache nicht und sprechen auch von
wahlfälschung belegen gibt es bislang
dafür nicht aber was hier also auf
dieser seite eben gefordert wird von von
seiten der tram fans ist ganz klar auch
hier sollen neu ausgezählt werden
das heißt alisa wir können jetzt leider
nicht sehen aber müsse es ist wirklich
vorstellen auf der einen straßenseite
auf der anderen straßenseite völlig
unterschiedliche meinungen und felder
das ist ganz genau richtig also es ist
wirklich ist die straße dazwischen und
dann steht die polizei dazwischen die
stimmung ist friedlich die stimmung ist
ruhig da ist auf der einen seite bei den
menschen eben die fordern jede stimme
zählt ist tanz musik und aber auch auf
der anderen seite also bei den fans da
ist die stimmung ruhig die haben einfach
ja wirklich mühe machen von ihrem recht
der freien meinungsäußerung gebrauch und
das ist auch vollkommen in ordnung so
unterstehen sich einfach
unterschiedliche meinungen gegenüber
ich habe gesprochen mit den fans und ich
habe auch dort gesprochen mit einem
wahlbeobachter der erzählt hat also in
seinem distrikt wo er eben selbst
beobachtet hat da sei alles mit rechten
dingen zugegangen aber er hätte gehört
von und das ist eben so ein bisschen der
punkt also alle haben jetzt von
wahlfälschung gehört ich meine das ist
ja auch das was der präsident die ganze
zeit sagt im zweifel haben sich also
vielleicht von ihm gehört aber was da
also dringend jetzt gefordert ist oder
was was es braucht sind also beweise und
belege dafür
und dann kann man ja im prinzip auch
dagegen klagen dieses recht besteht ja
und dann muss das aber geprüft werden da
müssen also beweise dafür auf dem
also man merkt was du sagst es ist eine
angespannte stimmung
wir müssen uns aber einfach noch mal
auch richtig vor augen führen
schauen wir uns einfach nochmal an wie
knapp das ganze ist wie diese
entwicklung in den letzten stunden ist
die verschiebung der vorsprung was
dahingeschmolzen ist bei trump was
beiden dazu gewonnen hat und zwar in
georgia und in pennsylvania schauen wir
uns diese entwicklung der letzten
stunden noch mal in georgia hatte trump
am wahltag noch mit mehr als 300.000
stimmen vorne gelegen doch beiden konnte
aufholen und hat den amtsinhaber sogar
überholt zurzeit hat er über 1500
stimmen mehr
in pennsylvania sieht es so aus am
wahltag lack trump hier noch mit 700.000
stimmen vor beiden heute morgen überholt
joe biden kramp und liegt im moment mit
über 9000 stimmen vorn
der grund für diese veränderung in
pennsylvania wurden zuerst die stimmen
vom wahltag gezählt und die vielen
mehrheitlich für trump aus schon vor dem
eigentlichen wahltag stimmten aber
zehntausende für beiden es ist ja so in
pennsylvania es ist ja sowieso spannend
weil ja jeder us bundesstaat eine ja
sozusagen andere regeln hat hier können
briefwahlstimmen schon vor dem dritten
november vor dem wahltermin ausgezählt
werden pennsylvania ist es anders da
dürfen ja die stimmen wenn sie den
poststempel dritter elfter haben nicht
nur am mittwoch nicht nur am donnerstag
sondern eben heute am freitag ausgezählt
wenn das ja klar dass dann heute noch
ausgezählt wird ist das dann so dass das
eine vielleicht die leute verzweifelt
lässt war noch gar keine entscheidung da
ist aber dass es trotzdem ja mit dem
system mit dem korrekten wahl regeln zu
tun hat
natürlich das dauert hier einfach ein
bisschen länger du sagst es richtig also
bis bis heute einschließlich heute
dürfen eben hier in pennsylvania also
noch briefwahlstimmen eintreffen und
ausgezählt werden solange sie dann den
poststempel vom dritten november haben
dass da gibt es auch ein urteil zu vom
supreme court also von zuvor
es ist also rechtens und das ist aber
jetzt auch ein bisschen interessanter so
hört sich jetzt das narrativ auf
verändert von seiten der tram fans in
den letzten tagen hieß es ja lange
stoppt die auszählung stoppt die
auszählung das war also die die ganze
zeit das narrativ jetzt weiß man man
kann es nicht mehr stoppen es ist ja
auch wirklich schon fast am ende und
jetzt heißt es also es soll neu
ausgezählt werden aber das vielleicht
auch ganz interessant also ich jeden
fall semenya ist sowieso vorgesehen
wenn also dieser unterschied zwischen
den beiden zwischen beiden und scham
gering sein sollte also sehr sehr gering
nämlich 0 5 prozent dann wird hier
sowieso automatisch neu ausgezählt also
hier das demokratische prinzip und das
war prinzip das funktioniert ja hier das
wird jetzt also hier alles seinen gang
gehen und deswegen ist so ein bisschen
die frage auf warum jetzt schon die
große aufregung es tatsächlich
du sagst das man haben muss einfach
geduld haben und jetzt müssen wir
einfach noch mal eben auf schotter
zurückblicken
da war es ebenso als der secretary of
state brad pitts bürger gesprochen hat
und eben erklärt hat dauert alles und
dürfte auch noch mal zu einer
neuauszählung kommen da wurde er von
journalisten auch gefragt na ja wie
lange kann das denn am ende dauern er
sagte wir wollen mal den 20 november an
aber es versuchen es natürlich früher
hinzukriegen zwanzigster november das
zeigt man muss schon sehr sehr sehr viel
geduld haben und es läuft nicht ganz so
ab wie vielleicht bei uns hier in
deutschland
alisa du hast es aber gesagt vom spricht
von wahlfälschung kommt mit
verschwörungstheorien an
wir wollen uns mal anschauen er hat ja
in der nacht noch mal gesprochen er hat
ja nach dem dritten nach dem wahltag in
der nacht schon sich zum sieger erklärt
das hat ja schon für reaktionen
unverständnis kopfschütteln auch schon
bei seinen parteifreunden geführt jetzt
hat er sich in der nacht noch einmal
gemeldet und das spannende ist daneben
auch dieser so einige us sender reagiert
haben dann schauen wir uns einfach mal
gemeinsam
wir sehen also dass die fernsehsender
einfach rausgegangen sind aus dem aus
der live übertragen weil sie gesagt
haben was er da erzählt das passt alles
nicht das hat hinten und vorne hat das
nichts mit der wahrheit zu tun wie haben
die menschen denn darauf reagiert die
das nachts gesehen haben
das ist vielleicht aber auch so ein
bisschen hier der punkt also ist es gibt
ja viele hier auch gerade von den tram
fans die haben sich abgewandt von denen
von den medien die schauen das ja gar
nicht mehr worauf die nämlich schauen
und blicken dass es also twitter und auf
das was der präsident dort selbst
twittert also die nehmen mit sicherheit
war und er teilt dann ja auch das was an
der pressekonferenz gesagt hat das
dringt also zu denen durch und das ist
aber jetzt eben wer spannende punkt also
was vor allem ankommt sind worte des
präsidenten und eben nicht die
einordnung durch die medien und da wäre
es vielleicht jetzt auch ganz gut dass
wir mal von tritscher der heute im
rausgegangen ist von donald trump und
der auch wieder von twitter markiert
wurde weil er eben möglicherweise da
falschaussagen beinhaltet und zwar
spricht der präsident davon dass er ganz
einfach isele die die präsidentschaft
gewinnen würde wenn eben nur und er
nennt es legale stimmen gezählt werden
würden
und er spricht als er macht den
unterschied er spricht also von legalen
und illegalen stimmen das macht er ganz
bewusst er möchte seinen worten dadurch
mehr gewicht geben und mit legalen
stimmen damit meint er also all jene die
bis zum dritten november eingegangen
sind mehrheitlich an den wahlurnen und
mit illegal meinte all jene die via
briefwahl eingegangen sind und jetzt
also noch rechtens nachträglich
ausgezählt werden
aber das ist also das narrativ was hier
übernommen wird auch von denen von den
fans und hier wird jetzt also im prinzip
schon ganz klar gesagt das geht hier
doch nicht mit rechten dingen zu und das
wort illegal wird also benutzt alisa
dann fehlen vielen dank bewusst das
weiter beobachten vielen dank und jetzt
hier im studio haben wir professor
alexander thiele staatsrechtler von der
ludwig maximilians um
wenn sie denn in münchen herzlich
willkommen wir haben darüber wir wollen
ja über diese wahl sprechen und sofort
anknüpfen an das was alisa gesagt hat
spricht immer von einer gestohlenen war
ihm würde die wahl gestohlen alissa hat
gerade erzählt er sagt er hätte ja
eigentlich locker gewonnen wenn man die
legalen stimmen zählen würde
und wenn man die illegalen zählt dann
ist es eben so dass man wohl ihm die
wahl klauen will
was sagen sie dazu was beschwört er denn
da also zunächst einmal glaube ich ist
er frustriert vor allen die noch mal mit
mir
er ist jetzt frustriert und weil er
frustriert ist scheint er eben weil die
war sehr knapp ausgegangen ist denkt er
sich jetzt aus dass er doch eigentlich
nicht verlieren konnte und deswegen
findet er jetzt fast schon verschwörungs
geschichten warum die wahl jetzt für
beiden ausgegangen sein könnte
das ist natürlich nichts was rechtlich
irgendwie standhält einer prüfung also
die gekränkte eitelkeit des donald trump
ist kein rechtliches argument für ein
gericht sondern das braucht dann schon
harte fakten das heißt wir müssten dann
jetzt mal genau schauen wo vielleicht
irgendwo was schief gelaufen ist
es ist knapp aber das heißt eben nicht
dass was schief gelaufen ist und dafür
dass wirklich ernsthaft rechtsverstöße
aufgetreten sind dafür spricht gar
nichts weder die wahlbeobachter auch die
amerikanischen sagen dass noch sonstige
stellen bringen irgendwelche belege
dafür dass hier wirklich substanziell
was gegen das gesetz gelaufen ist er hat
ja schon in der nacht vom dritten auf
den vierten november gesagt er sei der
sieger gleichzeitig hat er gesagt er
würde zum supreme court gehen und über
facebook schreibt uns gremien kann der
supreme court die wahlen denn überhaupt
annullieren wenn trump jetzt hier irgend
eine manipulation anführt etc was ist
damit gemeint wenn trump sagt ich gehe
zum supreme court kann er das machen und
kann der supreme court am ende wirklich
eine entscheidung treffen also tram
zeigt hier wieder mal dass er jetzt
nicht so richtig durchdrungen hat wie
das ganze funktioniert das muss man
glaube ich mal sagen er kann nämlich
nicht direkt zum supreme court
jedenfalls nicht sofort sondern er muss
erstmal weil es ja bundesstaatliche
wahlen sind in allen bundesstaaten
schauen in den einzelnen 50 wo was
schief gelaufen sein könnte
und dann muss er zu den
bundesstaatlichen gerichten gehen und
muss diese bundesstaatlichen gerichte
dann darum bitten
das zu überprüfen das müsste dann in der
ersten zweiter instanz möglicherweise
vielleicht auch direkt zur jeweiligen
staatlichen supreme court gehen dann
müsste die entscheidung gegen jumper
gehen und dann könnte er eventuell auch
zum supreme court ich glaube allerdings
nicht dass er ernsthaft glaubt dass
wirklich was schief gelaufen ist sondern
möglicherweise seine strategie er dass
er versucht zeit zu gewinnen und das
könnte ihm verfassungsrechtlich
tatsächlich nutzen
da müssen wir nochmal gleich weitergehen
wir haben auch noch einige fragen dazu
ich erinnere mich sehr gut an die wahl
2000 das ist der hammer gewesen
vielleicht erinnern sich einige andere
auch daran george double you bush gegen
al gore der demokratische herausforderer
und am ende wurde gezählt und gezählt
und gezählt da war es klar dass es auf
den staat florida ankam wer als den
letzten starts leider gewinnt der
gewinnt diese präsidentschaftswahl und
dieser stadt war heiß umkämpft und am
ende wurde gezählt und gezählt es gab
technische probleme mit lochkarten et
cetera und dann musste wieder ausgezählt
dann wieder ausgezählten bis der supreme
court am ende sagte jetzt ist schluss
jetzt bleiben wir hier und jetzt ist
feierabend am ende waren es 5 137
stimmen mit denen dann george hw bush
florida gewonnen hat und am ende us
präsident geworden ist das hat ungefähr
vier fünf wochen gedauert kann das jetzt
wieder passieren
es fragt ja auch eine zuschauerin
christina wolf fragt nämlich kann das am
ende wirklich hier monate wieder dauer
also die situation 2000 ein bisschen
anders gelagert das muss man sehen
damals sie haben es angesprochen gab es
probleme mit den lochkarten da wurden
die stimmen gestanzt muss das wirklich
vorstellen mit einer stanzmaschine und
was durch gestanzt war war eine ja
stimme für die für den jeweiligen
kandidaten und nun gab es übrigens vor
allen dingen den ärmeren counties von
florida veraltete wahlmaschinen und die
haben nicht so ganz durch gestanzt und
dann war die rechtliche frage ab wann
ist eine stimme eigentlich gültig
abgegebenen also wie viel muss weg
gestanzt sein damit die stimme
tatsächlich dann zählt und das war die
rechtsfrage um die es ging und da es da
keine einheitlichen standards gab kamen
die unterschiedlichen nachziehen
verfahren immer wieder zu einem anderen
ergebnis weil sie mal dass eine
mitgezählt und das andere nicht
mitgezählt haben einheitliche standards
gab es nicht und das
dann tatsächlich auch vor gericht
gegangen des supreme court hat dann
irgendwann gesagt nämlich anfang
dezember weil die eigene fristen haben
jetzt ist schluss mit nachzählen wir
haben jetzt auf die entscheidung ist
inhaltlich von juristen stark
angegriffen worden sie ist überhaupt
nicht überzeugend sie war auch
tatsächlich an den linien der
konservativen richter gegen die
demokratischen richter ausgerichtet aber
das entscheidende war dann unabhängig
davon wie juristisch haltbar das ist
dass der unterlegene kandidat al gore
ist akzeptiert hat und zwar sofort er
hat gesagt alles klar
der supreme court hat entschieden damit
ist jetzt georgia billy bush unser
präsident und ich ziehe mich zurück das
muss ich gestehen sehe ich bei donald
trump ist er nicht blinkt wir einfach
noch mal sie haben die wahl gerade so
schön beschrieben aber blicken wir
einfach noch mal gemeinsam auf diese
wahl 2000 zurück der eine hat sie
vielleicht nicht erlebt der andere mag
sich nicht mehr erinnern aber es hatte
schon was wie sie sagen eben mit
lochkarten und diesen ganzen technischen
problemen
erinnern wir uns einfach nochmal an
diese war vor genau 20 jahren
siebter november 2000 amerika
entscheidet wer ins weiße haus einzieht
der demokrat al gore oder der
republikaner george w bush ein enges
rennen stunden lang geht es in der
wahlnacht hin und her florida wird zum
zünglein an der waage mehrere tv sender
melden schließlich busch liegt hier
vorne seine fans jubeln l gratuliert zum
sieg doch dann ist klar dass eigentlich
nichts klar ist
gestern wählten die amerikaner einen
neuen präsidenten
und heute kann noch keiner sagen für wen
sie sich denn nun entschieden haben
das ergebnis ist knapp zu knapp es muss
nachgezählt werden nicht einmal nicht
zweimal fünf wochen lang wird gezählt
und vor gerichten gestritten
zuviel gingen hier schief schließlich
entscheidet der supreme court und damit
zum ersten mal über eine
präsidentschaftswahl dort stabil busch
gewinnt florida und wird der 43
präsident der vereinigten staaten 5 137
stimmen haben am ende den ausschlag
gegeben
5 137 stimmen wirklich der knaller wenn
man sich daran erinnert man fragt sich
natürlich automatisch kann sich das
wiederholen dieser albtraum des fehlens
von 2000 jetzt 2020 aber sie haben schon
gesagt es ist nicht alles gleich wie
2003 gab es technische probleme und da
gab es auch ein herausforderer oder
einen kandidaten der das akzeptiert hat
die sehen sie das heute
also ich glaube ich dass ich das so in
der form wiederholt die rechtsfragen
sind eher unterkomplex muss man
vorsichtig zu sagen im vergleich zu
damals die stimmen abgegeben worden dass
die alle zählen ist eigentlich relativ
unzweideutig damals bei der einen oder
anderen mal fragezeichen geben aber es
ist nicht so wie in florida wo dann
wirklich eine große zahl an stimmen vor
allen dingen übrigens in ärmeren
counties nicht gezählt wurde
das haben wir diesmal nicht sondern ich
glaube die rechtsfragen sind eigentlich
eher ja nicht so entscheidend und ich
glaube wie gesagt auch nicht dass trump
unbedingt glaubt dass er diese
rechtsfragen gewinnen wird sondern es
bleibt dann erst mal aber lange in der
schwebe weil die gerichtsverfahren
natürlich laufen die müssen entschieden
werden es gibt eine ganze armada an
anwälten die da durch die gegend und
jetzt versucht alles anzufechten was was
irgendwie geht und das kostet natürlich
zeit in gerichte die angerufen werden
von den präsidentschaftskandidaten sogar
dem amtierenden präsidenten entscheiden
das natürlich nicht einfach mal so
sondern überlegen sich dann schon und
clowns das natürlich auch genauer an und
diese zeitspanne die eben relativ lange
andauern kann
die könnte trump eben nützlich sein um
am ende vielleicht dann doch im amt zu
bleiben
aber das müssen sie mir doch mal
erklären oder uns erklären denn soweit
ich weiß gibt es doch nun eigentlich
klare regeln
bis zum 8 dezember müssen alle staaten
sagen welche wahlleute sie losschicken
zur wahl die findet am 14
dezember statt und dann wird gewählt und
am 20
muss es die vereidigung geben das ist
doch in der der konstitution in der
verfassung ja auch verankert was wie
kann eigentlich kommt dann auf zeit
spielen das ist der punkt
sie haben es richtig angesprochen das
problem ist genau diese frist der achte
dezember den sie richtigerweise genannt
haben die safe harbor date sozusagen wo
alle staaten ihre kandidaten benennen
müssen damit dann eine woche später auch
die wahl stattfinden kann im elektro
college diese frist steht fest und nun
ist aber unklar was eigentlich passiert
wenn bis dahin nicht klar ist welche
wahlmänner und welche wahlfrauen
eigentlich entsendet
werden weil eben in dem jeweiligen
bundesstaat die abschließende
entscheidung noch nicht da ist
und da gibt es tatsächlich konservative
verfassungsrichter auch vom supreme
court die sagen in einer solchen
situation wenn also is to close to call
ist auch an einem tag der kurz vor dem 8
dezember ist dann besteht die
möglichkeit dass der jetzt das jeweilige
staatliche parlament in dem fall zum
beispiel kongress von philadelphia sagt
von pennsylvania entschuldigung sagt wir
entscheiden jetzt welche wahlmänner
geschickt werden denn dass die
abstimmung ist leider unklar
und jetzt haben wir die kompetenz das zu
entscheiden und verrückter weise steht
auch genau das so in der verfassung denn
in der verfassung steht überhaupt nicht
dass die staaten die ja die wahlmänner
entsenden und wahlfrauen das wählen
lassen müssen sondern an sich könnte der
jeweilige das jeweilige parlament des
bundesstaates auch einfach selber
entscheiden wen sie schicken
das machen die natürlich alle nicht
sondern habe mittlerweile alle sich
dafür entschieden die wahl ablaufen zu
lassen
aber was eben passiert wenn diese wahl
unklar ausgeht das ist nicht geregelt
und wir haben diese enge frist deswegen
können wir nicht ewig nach zählen also
könnte dieses auf zeit spielen für trump
funktionieren verfassungsrechtlich
jedenfalls theoretisch funktionieren
wenn dann diese entscheidung vom
kongress in pennsylvania getroffen wird
und des supreme court bestätigt das wäre
ja höchst undemokratisch wenn gewählt
wird und am ende spielen die stimmen
keine rolle und es wird einfach so
bestimmt wir sind schon viele fragen was
dieses system angeht und wir wollen
einfach mal hier die fragen aufnehmen
martin um versuchen sie schnell auch zu
beantworten und zu claire martin l zum
beispiel schreibt mit pennsylvania im
rücken hat beiden dann doch schon mehr
als 270 wahlleute stimmt haben wir eben
gesagt deshalb ist pennsylvania mit 20
war leuten ja so spannend er hätte 273
gewinnt joe biden pennsylvania ist er
durch gewinnt donald trump pennsylvania
dann hat er noch nichts die wird er ist
eben dann zunächst einmal durch ist ja
noch kein endliches amtliches
endergebnis sondern wir haben dann
einfach nur cnn die uns dann sagen und
vielleicht auch fox news das beiden
jetzt vorläufig diese 273 faymann hat
aber es ist ja auch knapp als man bei
allem gebäude eines donald trump muss
man ja sagen demokrat hat damals auch
nachziehen lassen es ist ja auch
unfassbar knapp und die entscheidung ist
ja unfassbar wichtig nicht nur für die
usa sondern natürlich auch für die welt
in irgendeiner form und dass der
unterlegene kandidat wenn ein paar
tausend stimmen bei insgesamt 140
millionen stimmen abgegeben worden sind
zu wenig hat dass er da noch mal
nachgucken lässt das finde ich erstmal
nicht verwerflich ist ja auch richtig
dass das passiert das verwerflich ist
hier eher das trump so tut als wäre das
alles schon betrug und er wahrscheinlich
dann auch dass endlich das amtliche
endergebnis nicht akzeptieren wird
und jedenfalls ist der neuen
administration zu schwer machen wird wie
möglich wir kommen auf trump nochmal ich
möchte aber ganz schnell hier die frage
noch mal in den raum werfen von mira
längen
sie sagt einfach wir haben verständnis
dafür weil man sich ja selbst mal fragt
wie läuft das da eigentlich bei denen
wenn man das system daher versteht ich
verstehe das system nicht wirklich trump
hat doch viel mehr staaten für sich wenn
wir also auf die karte gucken wie wir
eben gesehen haben ihre längen hat da
wahrscheinlich recht sind doch viel mehr
staaten die rot sind und warum liegt
beiden trotzdem vorne kurze erklärung
kurze erklärung es komme auf die
bevölkerung an und wenn wir das es gibt
bei twitter ich habe das gesehen gibt es
eine stadt ist eine simulation da
schrumpfen dann diese roten staaten zu
ihrer bedeutung dass die bevölkerung
angeht und dann sieht man dass das
ziemlich gleichauf ist also die
bevölkerung ist eben an der ost- und der
westküste viel größer
die sogenannten etwas despektierlich fly
over states genannten unglaublich
weitläufigen staaten haben sehr viel
weniger einwohner und darauf kommt es
natürlich an nicht auf die größe des
jeweiligen bundesstaates oder vielleicht
darf ich noch eine sache zu dem
verfahren sagen weil es natürlich heute
wirklich anachronistisch und überholt
wirkt aber die ursprüngliche idee war
eben eine ganz andere und die ist eben
nie geändert worden
obwohl das verfahren heute in den
bundesstaaten anders laufen die
ursprüngliche idee dieses wahlmänner
gremiums und dieses wahlfrauen creme und
zwar eben nicht dass die bereits einen
fertigen kandidaten haben nur noch
abnicken das ist sowas hätte sich ja
auch keine ausgedacht das ist schon
ziemlich absurd das haben wir erst seit
mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts das
ist also kandidaten gibt die vorher
feststehen und die wahlmännern und
wahlfrauen nur noch diesen per diese
personen bestätigen
ursprünglich sollten die tatsächlich von
den bundesstaaten entsandt werden ein
elitäres gremium so hat man sich das
vorgestellt das dann gemeinsam aus allen
staaten zusammengesetzt über den
präsidenten bestimmt und zwar auch über
die person des präsidenten bestimmt und
dann wirklich frei darüber abstimmt
sozusagen ein überbleibsel aus diesem
gedanken ist ja das ist weiterhin ein
heimliche wahl ist die sie ja dann am 14
richtig machen also nicht offiziell
namentlich so wird es ja ungefähr heute
erwartet der wahlmann oder die wahlfrau
die dorthin geschickt wird das sind dann
eben auch den kandidaten wählt den mann
erwartet und sie sagen es richtig dass
wird erwartet aber wir haben eigentlich
bei jeder wahl so ein paar abweichler
das hatten wir auch bei der jobwahl im
letzten jahr 2016 gab es also einige aus
dem etui college die nicht für trump
gestimmt haben obwohl wir das hätten tun
sollen
das hat sich nicht ausgewirkt weil er
trotzdem eine mehrheit hat aber wenn wir
mal das worst case szenario in
anführungsstrichen eines sieges von
beiden unternehmen nimmt die situation
ist 270 zu 268 wahlmänner hat dann
müssen nur zwei anders stimmen und dann
haben wir sechs ersten folge situation
die wahlzettel werden ausgezählt vom
kongress das passiert ja dann immer im
kongress in washington werden ausgezählt
dann am ende kommt raus so 270 für
donald trump und dann ich weiß es nicht
so genau
die denn die wahlmänner müssen zwar und
wahlfrauen eigentlich auch
bundesstaatliche sind sie verpflichtet
in der regel so abstimmen wie es ihnen
mitgeteilt wird aber wenn sie das nicht
tun ändert das ja nichts daran dass wir
für den anderen haben also problematisch
oder könnte jedenfalls problematisch
seien damit haben wir eine frage schon
beantwortet von dir ohne saal was wenn
einzelne wahlleute am ende ganz anders
abstimmen als erwartet also alexander
thiele hat es uns erklärt das ist
durchaus schon vorgekommen allein schon
bei der letzten wahl
das ist auch die frage von dennis
janssen gewesen treibt also viele um was
sozusagen diese juristischen sachen sind
und das ganze weitere prozedere
sowas passiert schreibt über youtube
justus hellwig wenn trump das ergebnis
nicht anerkennt also eher scheint ja
eben nicht anders anzuerkennen
und sie haben es ja eben schon gesagt er
versucht auf zeit zu spielen indem den
den juristischen weg eben geht könnte er
damit eben dann erfolg haben als ich hab
das gezielt er könnte theoretisch
verfassungsrechtlich erfolg haben wenn
zum beispiel pennsylvania sagt to close
to call und dann übernimmt der kongress
in pennsylvania diese auswahl der
wahlmänner
ich halte das für sehr unwahrscheinlich
dass das passiert weil die republikaner
jetzt auch schon sagen also so
instrumentalisieren lassen
wir uns nicht und das ist dann schon
demokratische farce sind wir das
zulassen und dazu geben wir uns nicht
her
ich glaube auch nicht dass die akzeptanz
in der bevölkerung finden würden das ist
ganz entscheidend also einfach nur
jemanden da vorne oder oben sitzen zu
haben
er war überhaupt keine akzeptanz mehr
genießt das funktioniert nicht und es
wird ja auch schon ruhiger und stiller
um trump muss man sagen also wir haben
schon die ersten stimmen der
republikaner die sagen was du da jetzt
erzählt dass auf dieser pressekonferenz
die wir gerade gesehen haben das ist
wirklich quatsch hör auf damit jetzt
lasst das mal sein und lasst die leute
zählen und möchte ich jetzt nicht da ein
und tue so als wäre das alles betrug und
so weiter wir wollen sie uns einfach
nochmal gemeinsam anschauen diese
pressekonferenz die donald trump jetzt
gegeben hatte und wo fernsehsender
rausgegangen sind und abgeschaltet haben
weil ja man muss eben sagen die
fernsehsender haben es gesagt aber sie
haben es ja auch schon gesagt einige
republikaner sagen eben das ist
eigentlich ungeheuerlich schauen wir uns
das noch mal also die kommentatoren die
rausgegangen sind sagen es ist in weiten
teilen gelogen es stimmt nicht mit der
wahrheit über ein und deshalb gehen wir
raus ich darf noch mal einfach mal auf
deutsch kurz erklären was er da auch
gesagt hat wenn man die legalen stimmen
zählt gewinne ich locker wenn man die
illegalen stimmen zählt dann können sie
versuchen uns die wahl zu stehlen
in allen wichtigen staaten lagen wir
weit vorne behauptet ram was einfach
nicht stimmt denn es gab staaten wo
beiden vorne lag und umgekehrt
und auf einmal auf wunder sind wurden
unsere zahlen die von zauberhand
heimlich immer weniger so stehlen sie
uns die wahl also wörtlich wie von
zauberhand
heimlich wurden sie immer weniger
das ist ja richtig verschwörungstheorie
und hat es ja eigentlich was so ein
bisschen was von märchen gibt es denn
irgendwelche anhaltspunkte ich meine es
sind auch wahlbeobachter sowohl von der
demokraten aber auch von den
republikanern höre ich immer wieder in
den wahlzentren ausgezählt wird ja so
ist es auch und tatsächlich gibt es
überhaupt keine
anhaltspunkte dass trump verschwörungs
anhänger ist das überrascht mich ehrlich
gesagt wiederum nicht das hat kennt man
vom letzten vier jahre wir erinnern uns
gleich es ging ja gleich los mit der
großen lüge dass er die größte
innovation kraut gehabt hätte als die
meisten leute die bei seiner vereidigung
waren aller zeiten und dann erinnern uns
dann kam
kelly ann conway mit den alternativ per
fax als in alternativen fakten das
beginnt also schon ganz früh das traut
sich seine eigene wahrheit macht wie sie
ihm gefällt
das überrascht mich nicht das problem
ist auch weniger jetzt dass gerichte auf
ihnen jetzt hören würden das problem ist
eher inwieweit die bevölkerung die ihn
gestützt und die eben nicht diese
nachrichtensender sieht darauf hört und
ist man eher hat die autorität des amtes
er ist der präsident der vereinigten
staaten der diesen quatsch erzählt ja
nicht irgendwer
und damit haben wir eine große gefahr
dass die anhänger gibt ja nicht wenige
radikale anhänger also einerseits das
für bare münze nehmen und dann
tatsächlich glauben dass die wahl hier
manipuliert wird und das ist ein
fundamentales prinzip von demokratischen
ordnung dass die wahl sauber läuft und
da regt man sich zurecht auf wenn man
das glaubt dass die wahl manipuliert
wird und dann führt er also hier jetzt
gewalt oder zumindest führt er hass
zwischen den parteien und das scheint
mir schon großes problem zu sein
darüber hinaus vielleicht noch einsatz
jump ist noch präsident also auch werden
jetzt beiden morgen zum sieger erklärt
wird er bleibt ja präsident donald trump
bis zum zwanzigsten januar mit allen
kompetenzen
das kann theoretisch ganz schlimm werden
aber es beginnt schon damit dass joe
biden zugang zum weißen haus braucht und
seiner demonstration zu planen dann
braucht die wlan passworte um es mal
ganz platt zu sagen man muss wissen wo
die toilette ist und wo die oldie
computer stehen das ist eine
übergangsphase wo beide seiten
eigentlich eng miteinander kooperieren
zusammenarbeiten das haben die
unterlegenen parteien immer sofort
gesagt ich werde jetzt alles tun damit
die neue administration gut arbeiten gut
starten kann
das sehe ich bei amtlich also ich meine
wir beide ernähren sondern wir alle
erinnern uns an die bilder wie barack
obama seinem nachfolger trump eben im
weißen haus wenig löschen allerdings
zähneknirschen aber trotzdem sozusagen
für die dinge erklärt hat wie das jetzt
wird steht in den sternen
normalerweise würde man ja sagen mein
gott das ist unvorstellbar dass der
präsident sozusagen sein amt als
oberster befehlshaber der streitkräfte
missbraucht wir haben aber in den
letzten wochen erlebt das jump auch
nicht davor zurückschreckt zu sagen ich
rufe man bei der army an wenn ich eine
demonstration auflösen will das hat ja
auch zu einem aufschrei geführt was sie
sagen ist ja eben auch ein punkt wir
haben alle gesehen die fernsehsender
einige fernsehsender haben gesagt das
sind lügen die können wir nicht mehr
einfach weiter senden sind einfach
rausgegangen das ist klar aber es gibt
auch sozusagen den das beispiel dafür
dass die unterstützer von tram genau wie
sie sagen dass sie aber eben darauf
anspringen und die polizei hat heute
einen anschlag auf ein auswahl aus zell
zentrum in philadelphia verhindert wo
eben trump anhänger republikaner
versucht haben dort reinzugehen mit
waffen das wurde zum glück vereitelt
reden wir nochmal mit alissa jung die
eben in philadelphia in dem battleground
state pennsylvania ist alisa treten wir
noch mal mit dir weil es viele fragen
gegeben hat konkret an dich von vielen
usern die sagen wird es denn heute eine
entscheidung in pennsylvania geben
es wird heute also hier direkt um die
ecke hier geht's rein da ist das
kongresszentrum da wird also der pole
stand die ganze nacht ausgezählt und
wird auch heute den ganzen tag über
weiter ausgezählt also wir warten hier
stündlich eben auf neue ergebnisse aber
man sagt hier auch ganz klar und das ist
übrigens auch was viele medien
tatsächlich sagen sie sagen das ist
wirklich der demokratische prozess der
brauch zeit also wir nehmen uns die zeit
um auch die stimmen auszuzählen weil
warum denn die eile
jeder will ja jeder jede seite möchte
dass das hier alles seine richtigkeit
hat und es braucht eben ein bisschen
mehr zeit hier um die briefwahlstimmen
noch auszuzählen weil die sind teilweise
in zwei umschläge verpackt da müssen
unterschriften verglichen werden es
dauert einfach ein bisschen länger und
die zeit möchte man sich hier aufnehmen
also wir müssen jetzt hier einfach
schauen und wirklich von stunde zu
stunde und vielleicht dann auch noch mal
von tag zu tag schauen also alisa
scheint es so ähnlich zu sein die in
georgia wo eben die offiziellen auch
erklärt haben alles läuft korrekt nach
den regeln wir wollen das so tore müssen
noch mal sagen dass secretary of state
in georgia ist ein republikaner und hat
eben gesagt es läuft alles korrekt wir
wollen aber auch alles korrekt machen
uns als ein zweites mal aussehen
um auf nummer sicher
zu gehen alisa wir haben gerade auch
über den vorfall gesprochen
mit diesen republikaner die versucht
haben ein auszählen zentrum zu stürmen
da reinzugehen hast du noch weitere
informationen darüber hat es ähnliche
fälle gegeben oder ist das sage ich mal
zum glück vielleicht ein einzelfall
es fliegt ein helikopter gerade über
meinen kopf könntest du bitte noch
einmal ein bisschen lauter deine frage
wiederholen ich habe mich nicht gut
verstanden selbstständig wir schieben
erst mal den helikopter beiseite und so
weiter machen vielleicht dieses zeichen
so also lieber leser doch mal einfach
die frage wir haben gerade ja hier
darüber gesprochen über diesen fall dass
trumps korte die pressekonferenz wohl
wirkung hat das eben aufgrund seiner
vorwürfe die vielleicht aus der luft
gegriffen sind so sagen es dann
zumindest die medien die sich
abgeschaltet haben aber dass doch
zumindest einige anhänger das sehr ernst
genommen haben also zu einem aus zell
zentrum gefahren sind und die polizei in
letzter sekunde sie davon abhalten
konnten konnte da rein zu stürmen also
ein anschlag auf ein brief als zentrum
durch republikaner verhindert hat hat es
ähnliche fälle gegeben hast du etwas
davon noch gehört oder können wir sagen
zum glück vielleicht ein einzelfall
also jetzt hier in philadelphia habe ich
das zumindest zu diesem zeitpunkt nichts
davon gehört also jetzt auch die
menschen die hier vor dem
kongresszentrum wo eben ausgezählt wird
stehen da es ist also tatsächlich so
dass jeder da einfach nur von dem
protest recht gebrauch nimmt darf frei
seine meinung zu äußern
da versucht also niemand das zentrum zu
stürmen und das wäre jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt möglich dass nämlich auch sehr
viel prozent polizei vor ort
nichtsdestotrotz also die stimmung ist
friedlich und hat sich hier
beispielsweise auch heute nacht noch
unterwegs war das war um drei halb vier
als zu später stunde war hier auch also
wirklich die straßen leer gefegt und da
gab es jetzt hier nicht solche versuche
aber es stimmt beispielsweise in detroit
michigan
da gab es solche vorfälle das ist
richtig aber jetzt hier konkret aus
philadelphia kann ich das für den
zeitpunkt jetzt gerade nicht bestätigen
dann denken wir erst mal ganz herzlich
alisa und gehen nochmal hier einigen
fragen nach die es gegeben hatte und
zwar fragt jemand georgia kommt es hier
wirklich zu neuauszählung
ich kann nur noch mal wiederholen was um
16.30 unserer zeit der secretary of
state gesagt hat derjenige der zweiter
geworden ist es gibt nur zwei kandidaten
also quasi der verlierer hat die
möglichkeit eine neuauszählung zu
beantragen es ist relativ nahe liegt und
sie alexander thiele haben es ja auch
schon erklärt auch die demokraten haben
genauso wenn sie hinten gelegen sind
eine neuauszählung beantragt das ist
reif er vor allen dingen wenn es so
hauchdünn ist der secretary of state hat
eben auch erklärt das ist auch völlig
korrekt wir wollen auf nummer sicher
gehen wenn es so hauchdünn ist dann ist
das auch als nach den regeln
das neu ausgezählt wird was bedeutet das
für das endergebnis muss die welt dann
noch länger warten wo wirklich noch mal
mehrere tage
die antwort ist ja denn der secretary of
state in georgia ist ja auch gefragt
worden und er sagte das zieldatum dass
wir dann wirklich sagen dass es unser
ergebnis ist der zwanzigste november wir
versuchen natürlich unser bestes früher
das hinzubekommen aber so ist sage ich
mal der zeitplan eben in georgia und
dann könnten noch gerichtsverfahren
natürlich laufen dann ist erst das
amtliche endergebnis da und sagt dann
kann noch angefochten werden
möglicherweise jetzt hat auch noch ein
user geschrieben anus moderner wie viel
einfluss können die armeeangehörigen
noch auf den ausgang in georgia haben
ich fand es auch ganz interessant der
secretary of state in gingerbread
ravensburger hat gesagt dass 4169
stimmen noch aus zu zählen sind
da zeigt sich erst mal was es heißt 99
prozent der stimmen sind ausgezählt also
4169 stimmen müssen ausgezählt werden
der vorsprung zu diesem zeitpunkt von
von beiden war 1500 also es ist man
würde sagen wir reden im promillebereich
so ungefähr
und jetzt kommt's 8000 stimmen von
us-soldaten im ausland die müssen auch
noch ausgezählt werden
es kann jeder im grunde genommen den
taschenrechner nehmen
und herausfinden ja dass auch diese
stimmen durchaus noch einen ausschlag
haben können aber auch noch mal zur
erinnerung georgia 16 wahlleute also
selbst wenn donald trump die doch noch
gewinnen sollte im moment sieht es nicht
danach aus aber selbst wenn er sie
gewinnen sollte und sollte joe biden
pennsylvania gewinnen dann hätte beiden
eben die mehrheit von 273 war leuten
hinter sich kommen wir aber nochmal auf
diese ganze juristische sache da fragt
genau dies zu tun wenn ich das richtig
aussprechen
es wird viel darüber gesprochen dass die
demokraten auch juristisch reagieren was
können sie denn tun um die schritte von
trump zu verhindern
eine gute frage ja ist eine gute frage
aber es ist eben wir haben tatsächlich
ein zweier gefechte wo der eine gewinnt
verliert der andere und dementsprechend
kann man sagen sollte trump irgendeiner
mit irgendeiner gerichtsentscheidung
durchkommen dann wird natürlich die
nächste instanz von der demokraten
eingelegt werden davon können wir schon
ausgehen also wenn wir beispielsweise
das szenario nehmen was wir gerade
hatten das szenario wo wir sagen das
möglicherweise jetzt der kongress von
pennsylvania die wahlmänner entsendet
natürlich wird dann joe biden dagegen
vorgehen und zum supreme court kommen
also es immer sozusagen ein wechselspiel
mal der eine mal der andere
und ich glaube nicht dass der beiden
großes interesse daran hat jetzt von
sich aus erstmal viele viele
gerichtsverfahren zu starten ich glaube
er dass er abwarten wird was job etwas
donald trump jetzt macht er hat
natürlich die möglichkeit andere knappe
starten vielleicht anzuzweifeln und auch
dort die nachzählung zu verlangen
beispielsweise aber joe biden geht ja
auch vom fairen prozess aus hat ja gar
kein grund und würde sich auch etwas
unglaubwürdig machen wenn er jetzt
überall beispielsweise wegen
vermeintlichen wahlbetrug zu klagen
würde das macht er natürlich nicht weil
er ja auch glaube ich tatsächlich und
nicht nur taktisch daran glaubt dass
diese wahl fair war
nichtsdestotrotz ich habe gehört gelesen
dass beide seiten zu spenden aufrufen um
die gerichtlichen verfahren finanzieren
zu können denn sowohl republikaner als
auch demokraten die anwälte und juristen
sind ja auch leben also die haben eine
mama da eine armada von 100
von leuten die für joe biden unterwegs
sind und die auch für donald trump
unterwegs sind und natürlich kostet das
eine unglaublich große geldsumme das
wird teuer je nachdem
wir müssen uns ja klar machen auch da
wohl nur donald trump klagt ist auf der
anderen seite den anwalt von joe biden
oder er mehrere anwälte von joe biden
die also das gegenteil behaupten das
heißt das wird natürlich teuer bei 50
bundesstaaten bei tausenden von counties
wo überall theoretisch geklagt werden
könnte und trump es zuzutrauen ziemlich
viel zu klagen um es mal vorsichtig zu
sagen könnte man vielleicht hingehen und
sagen dass das eher vorhersehbar ist es
ist so die medien melden dass beiden
team sozusagen hat bekannt gegeben dass
man bereits gespräche führt und zwar mit
republikanischer seite damit es im falle
eines wahlsiegs doch noch sozusagen zu
einem cent teurer zu einer doch
geregelten übergabe kommt ist das
möglich dass das beiden teams sagt okay
trump wird sich mit händen und füßen
wehren
aber wir müssen mit den anderen
republiken anderen reden dass wir ihn
irgendwie aus dem weißen haus kriegt
wenn beiden dann der endgültige sieger
wäre das ist glaube ich auch der
richtige weg den beiden jetzt gehen
sollte also wir haben tatsächlich man
wundert sich vielleicht darüber aber wir
haben immer noch ziemlich viele
vernünftige republikaner wie haben sie
ihre seele so ein bisschen verkauf den
letzten vier jahren aber ich glaube sie
merken jetzt auch an denen sie die ihre
eigene politische auffassung da verkauft
haben möglicherweise donald trump
verhält sich nicht klassisch
republikanisch ich erinnere da zum
beispiel an john mccain als er verloren
hat oder auch an george bush den älteren
als er verloren hat wie er dann eine
pathetische rede auf dem nächsten
präsidenten hält und sagt das ist jetzt
der nächste präsident und jetzt
bitteschön seid bitte für ihn das jetzt
unser präsident und wir müssen jetzt
alles tun dass dieser neue präsident
erfolg hat und dass genau das ist noch
vorhanden irgendwann nicht
republikanischen partei die ersten
stimmen gibt es ja schon
und je weniger unterstützung schauen in
seiner partei hat desto einfacher in
anführungsstrichen wird es oder
vielleicht besser desto weniger schwer
wird es dann auch den übergang im weißen
haus zu organisieren aber im weißen haus
muss man ganz klar sagen hat dort schon
das hausrecht bis 20 januar ja dann wenn
eigentlich normal die letzte frage sie
haben schon ein bisschen
angeschnitten aber hier kann auch die
frage wie viel schaden kann trump noch
anstellen solange er präsident ist da
der präsident der vereinigten staaten
kann generell relativ viel schaden an
stellen und zwar unabhängig davon ob er
jetzt gerade frisch wiedergewählt wurde
oder nicht er hat noch drei monate zeit
ich glaube nicht dass es ernsthafte
alternative ist oder eine option dass
das militär auf seine seite bringt oder
ähnliches dafür ist das alles zu
demokratisch fungiert in und grundiert
in der in der demokratischen
amerikanischen gesellschaft aber er kann
natürlich trotzdem versuchen zum
beispiel über sogenannte executive
orders dekrete noch politik zu machen
das müsste dann möglicherweise
verfassungsrechtlich vielleicht eher der
kongress machen aber er kann es ja erst
mal machen und gucken dass einer klagt
er hat ja nichts zu verlieren in
anführungsstrichen mehr
er ist am 20 erster raus nach dem motto
nach mir die sintflut so ein bisschen
das ist nicht ausgeschlossen und dessen
er verhält sich wie ein kleines kind und
dementsprechend ist das sogar möglich
vielen vielen dank für die einschätzung
ich glaube wenn wir das alles zusammen
nehmen was sie jetzt erzählt haben
erklärt haben die fragen die gekommen
sind und die wir versucht haben zu
beantworten was auch alisa in
philadelphia erzählt hat dann ist es
glaube ich nicht übertrieben was wir am
anfang gesagt haben dass dieses
auszählen dass diese us-wahl 20 20
spannender ist dramatischer ist als je
ein drehbuch hätte geschrieben werden
können
das war auch unser zdf live zur zum
derzeitigen stand sie sehen ist dass ich
das mit einem schmunzeln sage bei den us
wahlen in amerika wir haben noch keinen
sieger wir haben noch keine klarheit es
gibt tendenzen joe biden liegt vorne es
wird immer knapper
in gewissen swing states in battleground
states wie pennsylvania und georgia da
haben wir drauf geguckt aber es ist auch
klar dass in den nächsten stunden nicht
unbedingt ein sieger feststeht und wir
haben gemeinsam auch analysiert welche
rechtliche schlacht noch wahrscheinlich
geschlagen wird insofern gilt das was
die beiden durchaus auch treffenderweise
gesagt hat wie patience and every single
what has to be counted also jede stimme
muss gezählt werden und wir brauchen
noch geduld
es bleibt also weiter spannend vielen
dank für ihr interesse düsseldorf wieder
sehen